glass is directed by M night Shyamalan
and stars James McAvoy Bruce Willis
samuel l.jackson and sarah paulson and
is the 19 year in the making sequel to
unbreakable and split which was a
surprise and breakable sequel that blew
a lot of people's minds myself included
and in this film we watched david dunn
use his supernatural abilities to track
kevin Wendel crumb eventually they end
up in a psych ward with mr. glass
himself being interrogated by a
specialist who believes they're under a
delusion that they're all superheroes
and she's trying to convince them that
it's all in their mind to say that I was
excited for this movie would be a
massive understatement in regards to
anticipation this is top 5 maybe even
top 2 I was so so ready for this film
unbreakable I consider a masterpiece and
split I loved so naturally being in this
theater
I was just pumped I was amped I was
ready glass has a lot to love the first
20 minutes are absolutely amazing they
were so good in fact that I was worried
I didn't understand how we could
possibly sustain such greatness for the
entire runtime
I loved the introduction to David Dunne
seeing what his life was like I I loved
so much about that opening especially
James McAvoy who is amazing throughout
the entire runtime once again and he is
worth the price of a ticket alone to see
him reprise all of these roles that live
inside of his mind he is absolutely the
best part of this film samuel l.jackson
also once he decides to become active in
regards to the story amazing really
great performance reminded me of his
work in unbreakable and Bruce Willis is
trying you're gonna hear that a lot
although his character felt left on the
sidelines for a lot of the movie which
we'll get into in a second the psych
ward scenes I was interested in and
although it feels a bit long and it
there's a sense of I don't know if this
was what I wanted to see it was still
fascinating especially as a story about
the human psyche and the human condition
and how we view ourselves along with the
rest of the world and I liked a lot of
the messages behind these scenes the use
of color was beautiful again same
cinematographer
from split really well shot film this is
a very well directed movie from start to
finish
Shyamalan definitely did not disappoint
in regards to that although there is an
overuse of POV shots that I would say is
my biggest issue with the cinematography
and the shot structure is there's a lot
of POV shots there's a lot of shots with
the camera mounted to the actor and it's
pointed at their face and you get sort
of like that GoPro look and didn't
always work for me that was overused but
overall the movie is gorgeous going into
this movie there's gonna be a lot of
people who will expect certain things
some people just want to see the
superhero action that was only hinted at
and unbreakable because if you really
think about unbreakable there's just one
shot where David puts a guy in a
chokehold and that's about it in regards
to action nevertheless that doesn't
bother me I love that movie it's a
psychological thriller and just one of
my favorites so I wasn't expecting this
movie to be like a Marvel movie in fact
I was really hoping it would be the
antithesis to that just the exact polar
opposite and in many ways it is I
actually got a lot more action than I
expected with the opening and some
things towards the end which we're all
done really well but I'm gonna have to
do a spoiler review because obviously
there are things in the finale I can't
get into here I'll do that later this
weekend I will say though that I was
very let down by it I struggled to
comprehend how this ending was chosen
amongst many others that you could have
chosen it's the kind of ending that does
not feel earned glass was such a
surefire thing so many fans people who
had been there with Shyamalan from the
beginning who had supported him through
his dry spell who really wanted him to
succeed and make great films like this
guy most of my subscribers know how much
his films inspired me and split was
great so I have been an M night
Shyamalan defender for many years and I
will probably continue to be because in
regards to films
give me a filmmaker who takes the risks
who tries to make an original movie who
puts out that vision over a filmmaker
who's just on the conveyor belt just
moving through the box office out of the
box office onto the next thing that's
not what Shyamalan does and I respect
him for that at the same time this was a
19-year movie in the making and the way
the film wraps up just really let me
down so much of it though
honestly loved it's a mixed bag of
shades of greatness and then baffling
decisions that I just can't comprehend
and it's one of the most frustrating
things about being a fan of Shyamalan
because you're constantly defending him
you're explaining to people why you like
his films and watching glass for for so
many sequences you can see wow this man
really knows what he's doing behind the
camera there's one shot of samuel
l.jackson wheeling away from something
and in the background some chaos is
happening and it's just incredible
there's sequences like that that
obviously show how talented the man is
behind the camera but then people ask
you questions like how can you defend
him so much when he does choices like
this and there's rarely justification
for those choices and you start to think
yeah you know I see your point I really
do and it's it's disheartening for
someone who's defended him for so long
to have been so let down by something
that I was truly looking forward to I'm
not sure if this ending will polarize
people I feel like there will be a lot
of people who really like the film and
appreciate the different direction
I actually am one of those people I do
really like the direction this movie
takes it's just the last 20 minutes that
make the rest of it have so many
questions
there's a lot of unanswered questions
and if you've ever actually had anyone
that was in some sort of institution or
you knew of the rules of an institution
you're just gonna constantly be asking
yourselves how these patients had access
to certain things there's something
that's used for James McAvoy's character
that's light that flashes on and off and
it forces him to change identities to a
safer one that's a really fun idea and
it gives us some great moments with
McAvoy as he shifts through these
performances but I just kept thinking
man if you want to get out just take a
pillowcase and wrap it around your eyes
or cover your eyes why do you have to
keep looking at the light you know
there's just little things like that
throughout the film that kind of bugged
me and I feel like I have to reiterate
this but I honestly didn't expect any
action in this movie I thought there'd
be like maybe one fight scene but
there's more than I expected and so it
has nothing to do with that it just
feels very anticlimactic for the
build-up of the two previous films and
by far one of my biggest disappointments
with the movie is that Bruce Willis's
character David Dunn barely has an R
he's so sidelined he's so in the
background his lines are even minimal
the musical score as well I love West
Dylan Thornton and what he did was split
and some of his music throughout the
film is wonderful but it was very
disappointing that there's hardly any of
James Newton Howard Zinn credible
unbreakable themes one of the most
overlooked soundtracks of all time I
really looked forward to hearing more of
that theme and it's barely used they did
some interesting things with flashbacks
that I'll talk about in the spoiler
review that I thought was a pretty smart
idea
but overall I was let down by this movie
I'm gonna give glass huh I'm gonna see
the film again this weekend before
assigning a letter grade to it because I
feel really conflicted right now there's
so much I loved and then other things
that just really really let me down and
so I want to see the film again also I'm
kind of becoming disenchanted with
grades I don't know I might just do away
with them entirely at some point in the
future but I will give this film a grade
I'll I'll check it out again this
weekend
this didn't diminish unbreakable or
split for me I still love those films
and I didn't hate this at all like I
just feel very conflicted by it and I
have to see it again guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]